An earthquake has shaken the Spanish island
of La Palma - the strongest tremor since a
volcano started erupting there last month.
No significant damage was reported, but scientists
say it's another sign that the eruption won't
end soon.
Already it's forced hundreds of residents
to abandon their homes.
But the natural spectacle is also attracting
tourists.
Captivated by nature's fury.
A fountain of magma gushing from the depths
of the Earth.
For almost six weeks, rivers of molten rock
have been flowing from Cumbre Vieja.
Lava, burning at a sizzling 1,300 degrees
Celsius.
The apocalyptic scene has become an unlikely
tourist attraction.
The local volcano emergency committee is offering
free shuttles for the catastrophe curious.
"You hear it and it`s like the world is coming
to an end, it`s impressive."
But many have also come to show their support
for the islanders.
Thousands have had to abandon their homes,
destroyed by the mighty volcano.
"We definitely want to contribute to La Palma’s
economy."
"That's why we came here"
"In a passive way, our way to help is come
here to visit the volcano, which is something
unique, but we contribute with money by spending
money at hotel, restaurants, car rental."
The eruption has hit local businesses hard,
as ash falls like rain, painting the usually
sunny island every shade of gray
Some areas - like here in Las Manchas - more
reminiscent of a lunar landscape:
"The ash cover is very thick.
The football, the soccer pitch down there
is, well, half up the goal posts covered with
ash and this will take many weeks and months
before this is cleaned up."
Experts say the latest earthquake could be
a sign it's far from over.
Ironically, not necessarily bad news for La
Palma's economy.